joe biden is going full speed ahead with
his cabinet yesterday we talked about
three selections secretary of state
national security advisor and ambassador
to the united nations today we have
three more actually four more to tell
you about which i will do momentarily
and as great as it is to see joe biden
do this it is also fascinating to watch
the car crash of donald trump
just being so triggered by joe biden
moving ahead
and selecting his cabinet yesterday when
i told you about
three of joe biden's elections i
mentioned some tweets that donald trump
sent over the weekend
about how mad he is that joe biden is
moving ahead
as joe biden continues to make
selections donald trump continues to
tweet despite donald trump having
effectively conceded the race by telling
the gsa
to move forward with the transition
donald trump tweeting
in certain swing states there were more
votes than people who voted and in
big numbers now since rudy giuliani has
said that's actually a bit
of an exaggeration trump going on to say
does that not really matter
stopping poll watchers voting for
unsuspecting people
fake ballots and so much more such
egregious conduct
we will win and with every announcement
from joe biden
another tweet from donald trump claiming
he will win
so we now have the privilege and i
really consider it that
that after four years of playing defense
and nonsense every day from this
administration
we are starting to get back into media
and substantive politics selections of
people
who are actually qualified to be in the
positions for which they are being
selected
and let's review where we are so far
with joe biden's choices
of course vice president kamala harris
that we knew she will be uh the first
female president
or vice president uh and a very
interesting selection
um one that in some ways progressives
are fearful of in some ways progressives
are welcoming
we know about kamala harris we knew
about donald uh
joe biden rather's chief of staff
selection ronald klein
who will be a very boring chief of staff
he will be scandal-free
and i expect him to last a while in
significant contrast to what we saw in
the trump administration
secretary of state anthony blinken we
spoke about yesterday
national security adviser jake sullivan
we spoke about yesterday
and ambassador to the united nations
linda thomas greenfield we also spoke
about that yesterday
interestingly after donald trump uh sort
of demoted
ambassador to the u.n and pushed it out
of the national security council
joe biden will be re-elevating
ambassador to the un
to a cabinet level role it will be part
of the national security council i think
that's important it shows that
you are taking seriously the
relationship to the united nations okay
we knew all of that yesterday
new selection from joe biden as the
cabinet is filled out
treasury secretary will be janet yellen
now janet yellen was previously the
chair of the federal reserve
and she will also be the first ever
woman
running the department of the treasury
now you know that i am not an identity
politics guy
uh i want someone who is qualified and
there is
no way to argue that janet yellen is
unqualified and
it is powerful and inspiring and
interesting
that she will also be the first woman in
that position she is going to get
a fragile economy in the midst of
coronavirus
with high unemployment almost certainly
yellen will be at the center
of a second coronavirus relief bill
which we have every
belief that joe biden as president is
going to try to put in place
she will have a massive undertaking that
she will be walking into on day one
uh and likely even before day one and
she will be tested right away
now in terms of yelling for markets
markets will likely
uh do do well uh as a result of this
markets early today liking this
selection
yellen is a known entity already
and of course for those who are on the
right and were worried about
oh socialism biden the socialist the
communist
the selection of janet yellen we'll talk
about the progressive reaction but the
selection of janet yellen if you are
in any way connected to reality should
confirm
that there is no socialism or communism
going on here
meanwhile there are lots of progressives
who are okay with janet yellen
she has gone after corporate power
in the past she went after wells fargo
during the fiasco years
she's not an ideologue and at least as
far as joe biden
is likely to pursue the economic agenda
he ran
on janet yellen is not the type of
person who is likely to get in the way
of any of it it will still be up
to biden to actually pursue that to
pursue it
some elements of it uh will be affected
by whether or not democrats take the
senate there are many ifsans and buts
but janet yellen is not someone who will
get in the way
of any of what joe biden wants to do
that he ran on
much of which was at least acceptable to
progressives okay we'll talk more about
janet yellen in the future
another very interesting selection
secretary of homeland security
will be alejandro mallorcas
first latino in this position also
a jewish man who has taken very
seriously the issue
of anti-semitism will be very
interesting to see him take that head on
as secretary of homeland security what
the policy uh questions will be right
away
include what does he do about family
separation
and the caging of children not trivial
things
that will be sorted out by the
individual in this position a very
interesting choice
director of national intelligence will
be avril or avril
haynes will be the first woman in
history in that position
how does she clean up this fiasco of
lack of trust
in the intelligence community as a
result of
four years of donald trump slamming them
she has her work cut out
climate czar this is a very interesting
position
john kerry will be climate czar
now merely having a climate and
environmental czar
is a move in the right direction kerry
is super smart
one of the people i met earlier on in in
hosting
the show this position will be on the
national security council
that's important recognizing that
climate is a national security issue
this is a really great thing now one
other thought
there are really interesting identity
stories here but
absent the identity stories there
are uh all qualified people in these
positions
and even folks on the right who are not
lunatics are saying we find that a lot
of these choices are too far left
but every single one of them is
qualified now in addition to that
there are interesting racial and gender
stories
to be told here and i don't think that
it is playing identity politics to
recognize that
we're going to do deep dives into the
politics of this cabinet once it's fully
selected
remember that these positions are
set for senate approval they depend on
senate approval
if republicans end up controlling the
senate
they are going to put up roadblocks for
joe biden for at least some of these
positions
it is conceivable that if republicans
really want to obstruct
joe biden may have no choice but to use
interim or acting appointments to get
around
senate confirmation remember that
republicans have been going on and on
about obama sat on all of these the or
rather the democratic senate under obama
for those couple of years
blocked all of these selections um we
are going to very quickly
see whether republicans are going to do
the exact same
same thing the upside right now is that
normal non-q anon
non-fascist non-ideological
extremist lunatic types are rapidly
set to be in charge of the country just
eight and a half weeks from now that's a
really important thing
last thought on cabinet and then we're
going to take a quick break
anti-semitism is already going crazy uh
because of the selections
there are some jewish folks who are
going to be part of
joe biden's cabinet and staff ronald
clayne his chief of staff
is a jewish guy kamala harris's husband
is jewish he he will have no formal role
but you know anti-semites don't care
about that
janet yellen is a jewish woman alejandro
mayorkas
is a jewish cuban guy the usual suspects
are already very upset
about the number of jews here and we are
already seeing that boil over in some of
the right-wing enclaves of the internet
the groups that track anti-semitism
online are already aware of it
and that i mean listen we'll have time
to talk about that but that is rearing
its ugly head once again
let's take a quick break let me know
your thoughts
uh about some of these choices i'm on
twitter at deepakman
um i got a bunch of emails people saying
david you sound sick
today no i'm just at a different uh
different studio different location for
the thanksgiving week using a different
mic i sound a little different i'm not
sick as of now could wake up sick
tomorrow but i'm not sick
we have not lost the studio we have not
been kicked out
the show is not circling the drain i am
just elsewhere this week
uh and we have a very very busy week of
shows upcoming
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book before
you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video